the world you know we published a lot of
books but this one was a special baby
here because we think it matters
Debora Greenspan thank you very much
thank you very much thank you Donald
Brownlee is a professor of astronomy at
the University of Washington and
co-author of the new book the life and
death of Planet Earth
he spoke about it recently at Powell's
bookstore in Portland Oregon for about
55 minutes okay I'm going to talk a
little bit about for the earth and space
before I talk about the earth and time
and the rare earth had to do with this
this is my wife and daughter in Maui and
this is a nice place but it's actually a
very rare place in the universe most of
the universe is actually quite hostile
to life and very few places have water
on the surface palm trees and people and
plastic chairs it takes very special and
air to breathe and restaurants to eat in
it takes very special requirements
environmental requirements for creatures
animals to live on and this doesn't
exist any other spot for animals in our
own solar system so even our own solar
system is rare in providing environments
for supporting higher life-forms so we
can look at planets now we're talking
about the earth in space now so this is
a buyer's guide so this is the earth and
these are our neighbors in the space
here's Venus over here on the right so
earth is good Venus is worst it's really
bad
forgetting about the temperature
temperature on the surface of Venus is
450 degrees centigrade so hot that any
molecules that ever you wouldn't life
out of it would break apart to the
thermal energy even when we spend
spacecraft to land on the surface of
Venus our electronics can't operate
there once the spacecraft lands it warms
up
a half-an-hour later it goes death
because semiconductors don't work at 450
degrees centigrate at least ones that
we've made so far but even far worse
than that there is no of course no ocean
because it's too hot and knowing that
it's a it's a it's a messy planet the
entire surface of Venus erupted about a
half a billion years ago covered the
entire surface of the planet with lava a
colossal environmental disaster so even
though that some science old science
fiction movies made in the 50s talk
about going to Venus you would not be
happy going to Venus it's a wonderful
place to explore but not by people or
any creatures from Earth so our other
neighborhood in space of course is Mars
Mars is 50% further from the Sun than we
are and because of that greater distance
and the fact that's only about half the
size of the earth
it's not a very habitable place at least
for advanced creatures microbial life
could exist right now under the surface
of Mars but the surface environments not
capable of supporting the creatures of
Earth so these are two extreme cases our
neighbors in space and you know you hear
a lot about Mars being earth-like well
it may be earth-like compared to Venus
but it's not a place you would like to
be it's a it's a wonderful place to
explore and we can go there and live
there for a short period of time like we
do in an aarika but you know long-term
causation and so forth is something that
maybe forever
beyond us okay and I'm not going to go
through all the all these factors but in
our book rare earth we listed a dozen or
so different factors which are required
to make the earth earth-like things like
the right distance from the Sun ocean
you need a certain amount of ocean but
you don't want too much why not too much
if there's a little bit more water on
the earth all the land would be covered
and once all the land is covered you
completely break down all these
wonderful thing
the result from the interaction of land
and sea and air they're actually
critical for a long-term stability of
Earth Jupiter actually plays a role
plate tectonics plays a role we'll talk
a little about a little bit later but
they're all these interesting factors
that go into making the earth earth-like
and we suggested in this book that this
is not very common we said it's rare
no how rare is rare we didn't no one
knows was one plan in 100 or implanted a
billion but nonetheless it's rare I mean
we as people or individuals are rare
just just think how unlikely each of us
in this room is you know we existed
because our mother met our father on a
street quarter and whatever you know all
these incredibly chance things it just
had to happen at the right time for us
to be here the earth is somewhat similar
there are all these sort of chancy
things that have to line up at the at
the right time
and the idea behind rare earth was that
animals like these bunnies up here are
pretty rare advanced life but that
microbial life might be pretty common
this is actually the most common kind of
life which is dominated earth and space
these are this is a microscope thin
section image it's on a rock that's been
sliced so it's about a thousands of is
thick and looked at in a microscope and
all those little creatures in here are
Canadians that lived in Ontario two
billion years ago in this church
gunflint shirt
these are cyanobacteria and you know if
you scrape your finger through the the
O's if they were still living you would
have billions of them on the end of your
finger this is the most common life
that's existed on earth through its
lifetime and it's probably the most
common kind of life that existed exists
on other planets also and this will
outlive us when are we animals and
plants disappear from the earth the
microbes will continue on possibly for
an appreciable period of time okay I
like to talk about the future now and I
just listed some events
and our planet future here and just for
we didn't talk about near-term too much
in the in the book but I put a list of
them here near-term with intense or say
hundreds of human generations so this is
the kind of thing that really you know
might impact us so we really shouldn't
ever get discouraged the fact that our
planets gonna die and very long you know
billions and billions of years now
because we're almost totally isolated
from that but at least we can imagine
things that would happen you know to our
offspring and you know tens or so of
generation so these are more real
problems and when human population
growth global warming energy solutions
you know how are we gonna have energy in
the future it is a huge problem that
people will solve it when one whoops one
way or the other
world peace hopefully someone will solve
that sooner than sooner than later
glaciation interesting factor here also
a slide of MacLeish iation next but the
most the book is about the far term the
things that happen on timescales
geologic timescales over a hundred
million years from now these include the
client carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
devolution you always think of life
getting better you know getting coming
from little things to big things well as
the Earth's environment degrades and the
long term life will devolve back to its
microbial beginnings the continents will
change they'll be mass extinctions fate
of oceans and plant life and finally red
giant son I don't have a slide of it but
a really interesting thing that happens
a couple billion years about three and a
half billion years from now we actually
collide with the Andromeda galaxy it's
not gonna be a biggie but it is
interesting that when the earth reaches
its final days that will no longer be in
the Milky Way galaxy it'll be in some
kind of new merger like corporate giants
they and Milky Way galaxy will merge
with his giant neighbor the Andromeda
galaxy in formed some new entity it's
coming is heading our
away and in about three billion years we
will interact and actually some
wonderful videos this computer
simulation of what this so will do on
the web just looked for collision within
Jarama
so on the short term this this is a plot
of temperature of the earth estimated
from Antarctic ice cores and just the
yellow line is temperature and it
bounces up and then down and then up and
down and up and down and up and down and
the timescale between these ups warm
periods of what we're in right now
called interglacial is about a hundred
thousand years and it's been doing this
for about two million over two million
years and we now live in an interglacial
period this lasted over ten thousand
years and they're an interesting point
you could plot on here's where the
beginning of Agriculture we we have
benefited greatly from living on the
planet
during this interglacial period many
people fear or you might predict that
we're ready to head into a new
glaciation when in Seattle and Canada
will again be covered with with ice
portland long but it probably seattle
will it's uncertain whether this will
happen or not but it's likely to happen
on timescales of maybe some thousands of
years into the future at least has done
it like a ringing like a bell for about
the last two million years another thing
that you can predict on the earth on a
somewhat short timescale is drifting of
the continents
this is the earth in the middle this is
the earth that we know today through
these accounts of North America South
America Africa Asia Europe and 250
million years ago the continents were
all together clumped together and the
continents are moving towards each other
and 250 million years from now they will
again be clumped and the clumping of the
continents wrap drastically changes you
know ocean circulation and climate and
so forth and this is a curious
phenomenon but one
to be concerned about is that this time
250 million years ago when the
continents were all together with the
time of the greatest global mass
extinction known when majority of
species on earth and everything larger
than a dog died in a really serious
about besides the origin of this is
unknown it wasn't it's not believed to
be a comet or asteroid impact it's
something the earth did itself maybe
carbon dioxide or methane belching out
of the the oceans so there is some
concern that maybe this will happen in
the future it's it's a it's a I say a
concern this is 200 a quarter of billion
years from now so it's it's more of an
intriguing episode than that an actual
concern to us today but it's nonetheless
it's it's a thing that planets like the
earth do now most of the really long
term changes on the earth there in fact
are predictable have to do with the Sun
so here's the Sun living with a nuclear
reactor the good the bad and the ugly
well the Sun has been great so far it's
our source of energy it's a source of
source of life it's terrific it's soon
gonna get bad in the sense it's going to
get too hot and the end it gets very
ugly actually it's very beautiful man
astronomers perspective but it's very
ugly if you're too close to to the fire
the problem is that a planet like the
earth flourishes as in a boat of life
because it's in this right distance from
the from a star so it's not so hot that
it's ocean gets vaporized into space and
not so cold that it's ocean freezes over
which is the case for Mars which is too
far from the Sun and Venus which is 30%
close to the Sun but it's too close so
the earth is in there's just nice spot
and that's why we're here but one thing
that stars do in time is they get
brighter and this is a remarkable plot
here this is the plot of the brightness
the Sun versus time so bright
is up and age of the Sun is to the right
so here's the Sun started here it's four
and a half billion years old right now
and it's going on here's ten billion
years here and why does it get brighter
and how do we know that it gets brighter
well astronomers have studied a large
number of stars and when you look at the
sky it's kind of like looking at a
forest with a snapshot take a picture of
a forest and you only look at it for a
short period time we take the picture
astronomers women working for well a few
thousand years if you want to really
really stretch it but with with modern
technology astronomers omean working for
a century or so but in that time been
able to look at this snapshot of the
other sky like looking at the you know
the picture of a forest and you can
deduce the life cycle of stars like when
you look at a forest you see little
twigs and bigger trees and bigger trees
and then rotten trees and trees that
have fallen over you can see the whole
lifecycle of a forest without sitting
there you know no Forester is set there
wast a tree for five hundred years to
see how it actually progresses they look
at trees in different evolutionary
stages and the same analogy is done in
astronomy to see stars and all these
different life cycles and one thing that
stars do you they all get brighter with
time and the reason for this is the
stars are nuclear reactors they're
turning hydrogen into helium and as they
do that the composition of the core or
the energy generation is occurring the
compasses the court changes if more
helium rich or actually fewer particles
in there in there it's like gas with
fewer particles has to be hotter to hold
up the weight of the overlying star and
as it gets hotter the nuclear engines
just run more and more efficiently and
generate more energy so the Sun is
slowly getting brighter it's 30 percent
brighter now than it was and was very
young which is kind of an interesting
mystery why why did inner ocean this
freeze over when the earth was young
it's still a mystery why what
but didn't at least didn't happen very
often but on into the future the Sun
just gets brighter and brighter and here
you know about five billion years from
now it's almost twice as bright as it is
right now
now superimpose on this is something you
probably noticed I put this yellow
stripe uten here it says age of animals
and before that first microbial age and
after that second microbial age so
there's another way of look at this as a
clock it's a clock of the Earth's and
the sun's full life history fortunately
a Sun the star of the same mass the Sun
can be a star converting hydrogen helium
generated energy for just twelve billion
years if the Sun was more massive it
wouldn't wouldn't last as long it burns
it punch it faster Kathy actually of the
Sun was twice as nasty but it already
would have burned out believe it or not
the Sun was less massive it would last
longer but our star with this mass will
last for 12 billion years so we can
represent that as a clock where each
number in the clock is 1 billion years
well right now the Sun and Earth are
four-and-a-half billion years old so
it's 4:30 on this clock and animals and
plants occurred first occurred in the
fossil record at about 4 billion years
or 4 o'clock on the clock life itself
started really early about you know
halfway to 1 o'clock and then there was
a period of you know microbial activity
in here inventing all kinds of fancy
interesting pathways and fighting with
with the earth struggling with the earth
and two and a half billion years after
the earth formed auction for the first
time started rising in in the atmosphere
before that any oxygen that was made by
little photosynthetic organisms would
rapidly react with things on the surface
and and be consumed but two and a half
billion years after star
after the earth began oxygen started to
accumulate and that made it possible to
have animals animals all animals require
oxygen to have energy to drive their
metabolism so but anyway the a lot of
evolution biological and physical
evolution of the plants basically the
planet was being terraformed into a no
livable planet over this period of time
it took four billion years that was the
idea behind rare earth that microbial
life would be common on earth as soon as
was physically possible to have any life
on Earth it's in the fossil record way
back in here but it took four billion
years to get to something as complicated
as a flower and anyway so we're now here
at 4:30 but about five o'clock five
billion years after the beginning the
end the age of plants and animals will
end and then there are various things
that happen in the future such as the
ocean being lost to space and so forth
and I'll just mention those a little bit
some of the interesting aspects of this
why do why is the age of animals and
plants and than a half a billion or
billion years or so why why is this the
Sun is getting hotter
but it's only getting hotter about 10%
every billion years so it's not much
hotter a half a billion years from now
so it's not just the heat amazingly
enough it's the carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere you know everybody is worried
right now this carbon dioxide gas
greenhouse gas is rising in our
atmosphere because we're burning almost
fossil fuels and it is and it's going
and it's causing us problems it's going
to be worse in the future but but that's
a short-term effect even if we burn all
the fossil fuels that we have in a few
thousand years the earth would be back
to its old tricks independent of what we
do in moving carbon dioxide over the
long-term of billions of years the
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere has
continually declined why would it do
that it does because of a number of
interesting complicated cycles
where carbon dioxide is actually
scrubbed out of the atmosphere now
what's important about carbon dioxide
carbon dioxide has a bad rap because
it's you know dangerous greenhouse gas
we shouldn't you know burn gasoline and
coal and oil because we're putting more
co2 in it well true we don't want much
more than there is in there now but we
need some the food of life is carbon
dioxide we you know it is our food
plants only grow because of
photosynthesis they they're made out of
co2 in the atmosphere and vegetarians
are dependent on plants so what happens
within the in the when the Sun gets a
little too warm the process is removal
of carbon dioxide become so efficient
basically the plants get starved that
the carbon dioxide drops to such low
levels and it is the lowest it has been
in geologic history right now I'm it's
slightly warming because of global
warming but over long timescales as low
as this ever has been in Earth history I
don't want to spell the time talking
about the details of this process but
this is a interesting process here how
carbon dioxide has cycled between the
the crust of the of the earth and in
back through volcanoes like Mount Saint
Helens in the atmosphere and then
returned by weathering back into the
ocean but the main removal process that
pulsed carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere is weathering rain on land
reacting with silicate materials
ultimately pulls the carbon dioxide out
deposits that's carbonates on the sea
horse sea shells right now on the on the
continents and this this process is
temperature dependent where the earth
gets warmer the scrubbing process is
more efficient this has been a wonderful
thing on earth because it's been a
thermostat that's prevented this kept
the earth a really constant temperature
for a very long period of time you know
when the earth gets a little too warm
this process becomes more efficient and
pulls this greenhouse gas out of the
atmosphere on long timescales not short
timescales like
civilization time so but I'm on longer
timescales and at the earth cools down a
little bit the weathering process slows
down let's this greenhouse gas cool
accumulate in the atmosphere in the
atmosphere warms up a little bit so this
process has been very beneficial but
when the Sun gets too hot the process
can't work and this weathering just
removes the gas carbon dioxide gas the
food of life out of the atmosphere so
the the end of the clock here the end of
the age of plants and animals happens
when the carbon dioxide gets below the
critical value for plants to grow now
maybe there will be intervention by
smart people at that time they'll figure
out some way but that to get around it
but if it just earth left to its natural
courses plants and animals will go well
Rison in about a half a billion years
from now which means let me go back to
the clock again one more time which
means that out of all of Earth history
it's only this little green band about a
billion years or so when the earth will
have advanced life on the surface as we
know it now so if you're Captain Kirk
and landed on the Earth's randomly in
time it would only be about one time in
ten that you looked around and saw
something that looked like yourself I
mean even yeah well even even if I'm by
even flatworms oh so other than that all
the life was microbial it was actually
invisible seeing only with the
microscope so what is the earth it
depends on when you when you look and
the earth as we know it now is different
than it has been in the past and in the
future no one should get discouraged
about thinking about the long-term fate
of the earth that's inappropriate to be
discouraged about it you know we can't
control nature we have to go with the
flow we can't make stars behave
differently we can't change the laws of
nature but we can't appreciate things
and we can't appreciate the fact that we
we're not on Venus on Mars we live in a
fabulous
planet and not only that you can look at
this clock here we live in in a really
good time you know we wouldn't be
talking we're back in back back in these
areas but so you know thinking of our
planet instead of sort of dissing our
planet and saying well it's a crummy
place you know we're gonna go somewhere
else or getting it better in the future
something we should be actually pleased
that we live us as a great place and as
much as we can we should try to preserve
the environment to the best of our
possible abilities because nature is not
going to do it you know a lot of people
have a lot of faith in nature that
nature wants to make everything great
for us well ask the dinosaurs about
nature you know they died been like that
from an asteroid or comet impact I mean
nature's not gonna help us out nature
can be good but it can also be really
really bad so we should really cherish
the environment that we are in okay so
I'll just skip that now I'll talk a
little bit about the ocean fact I have a
give a talk to the University of
Washington oceanography Department
tomorrow about this and one remarkable
aspect of the evolution of planets is
that they do in fact lose their oceans
they have to the start the start
eventually gets too hot and they and the
ocean has to be lost and there are two
ways that could be lost one it's called
the moist greenhouse effect and that
starts at about a billion years the
other end if the ocean is not lost by
this process it gets lost by the process
on the right here called runaway
greenhouse which will start in about
three and a half billion years the
runaway greenhouse is a really nasty
process where the ocean gets vaporized
and there's a lot of ocean and water is
a very strong greenhouse gas and the
greenhouse warming actually gets so hot
it melts the surface of the earth so you
can imagine what our planet would be
like with this runaway greenhouse effect
with all ocean or the water in the air
and it actually gets so hot it melts the
mountains it becomes a billiard ball
earth people believe that the ocean will
actually be lost before it gets a
runaway process but by this interesting
process called a moist greenhouse effect
which if it works will be a lifesaver in
the sense that lifesaver for bacteria if
you get rid of the water you can prevent
the earths from getting too hot and in
the future because a reduced greenhouse
effect and at least that the earth could
be habitable for bacteria to the very
end and I'll talk about the very end
very very shortly so this interesting
lost process our ocean being lost space
it's kind of nutty doesn't it this is a
picture of your earth right here this
the that's round thing in there is the
earth now this picture is a picture of
the earth taken in the ultraviolet and
this glow around the earth here is the
fluorescence from hydrogen gas escaping
the earth and that hydrogen came from
the ocean this picture remarkable
picture was taken from the moon by
Apollo 16 well the telescope mounted
actually on the surface of the Moon and
shows this Juke so the Sun is on the
left here and it's fluorescing this gas
coming off the sole you can actually see
water and measure its rate at which is
being lost from the earth that rates
pretty low it's so low it's only a few
meters of ocean every billion years but
in the future as the Sun gets warm and
warmer this process will it will
increase and ultimately lead to loss of
the entire ocean on this a time scales
of many billions of years you know three
or four billion years from now so these
are salt ponds in the south end of the
Bay Area San Francisco Bay Area and
these little colors put a little brine
shrimp then bacteria that growing up
there as they evaporate so we can expect
that one of the remarkable changes on
earth will be after being a beautiful
blue planet for billions of years
so if alien astronomers were watching
Earth
seeing it be a beautiful blue planet for
maybe seven or eight billion years and
then I go through a phase where it
turned this sort of pinkish orange and
eventually it would be all the oceans
would evaporate leaving a hundred metres
of salt or so probably with bacteria and
so forth growing in it at very high
temperatures that got Earth's got hotter
and hotter so that's the picture of bad
water lowest point the United States and
in Death Valley so the earth probably
will get reached the state a little bit
of water on the surface briny water but
in in in in how many years now this made
me a dismal state but again III you know
don't don't look at this in a negative
way and a good analogy I always think
about myself it's thinking back to Maui
first thought I should of Hawaii you
know you look at slide that you think
you say you don't say oh my god that's a
disaster because you know all those
Pacific Islands are doomed you know the
the natural life cycle of a Pacific
island like Hawaii is that the volcano
pops up above the ocean they're
wonderful they've got all these great
birds and trees and flowers and
everything grows there they're
absolutely fabulous but they're all
doomed because within a few short short
period of time geologically speaking a
few million years every one of those
islands sinks below the water and
anything that can't you know swim off or
fly off or float off goes down with the
island but that doesn't make it any more
any less wonderful it actually makes it
more wonderful because you want to
appreciate it while it's still above
water
now towards the very end the Sun does a
remarkable thing the first line I show
was a picture of an exploding star the
Sun won't actually do that and there's a
brightness of the Sun towards the end of
its life and there's the age starting at
12.1 billion years out to about twelve
point three one billion years and it
goes very high don't you can read those
numbers back there but the top number
this time
a thousand and the peak up here is about
five thousand so the Sun increases in
brightness by several thousand times
towards the end of its life at this time
it's called a red giant star it does
incredible things on its inside
including making carbon that's why we're
all all here but for planets like Earth
around the star it's curtains because
they get to hit it to extremely high
temperature and the earth itself is
actually just at the spot where the Sun
will actually expand out and just it's
not it's not precisely known whether it
be engulfed by the by the star or not
but the present best estimate is that it
actually will so the end our beautiful
planet will end up inside the Sun which
means every scratch of the planet will
be will be gone it's a long ways what
seven a half billion years from now so
finally I'd like to say about well what
about space travel something that always
comes up can we just leap off the planet
and go somewhere well maybe we can and
this is a this is a plaque I put on for
its it's in the picture of us in the
book this was on the Pioneer 10
spacecraft the first spacecraft that
went out at the solar system this little
pictogram of the bottom this the Sun
there's Mercury Venus and Earth so
laughs from the third Rock from the Sun
and went out here flew past Jupiter as
the spacecraft went out of the solar
system interesting sociological aspects
of this plaque this went out of the
solar system long after we are gone
I mean billions of years from now even
when the when the earth is gone this
plaque will still be floating around the
galaxy looking pretty much like it does
right now but when they put it up some
people complained about this they said
well first of all it's obscene because
it has naked people on it and it's
sexist because the man looks moored on
Earth
there were all kinds of interesting
comments about it this was actually
designed by Carl Sagan and Frank gray
and on the Voyager spacecraft they did a
more elaborate thing where they actually
put a record a record that had hundreds
of pictures of it and messages from
people on on earth it was a record with
a needle and instructions on how to put
the needle and record it but which is
amazing how technology changes you know
if you ask a kid right now what would
you do with a record because it would
never occur to any engineer today to
have an analog device but nonetheless
the sounds and pictures of Earth are you
know squirting out in in the galaxies
that will last Alex you actually outlast
our own planet and there is a lot of
expectations I know a lot of people
think that it's our fate that we will
either you know send ourselves out in
some form out on spacecraft and habitat
other other worlds I am a space
scientist that's that's what I normally
do about writing books I'm the Prez
investigator of the Stardust NASA's
Stardust mission so I tend to take it
some little hard-nosed patch close view
of this kind of thing because I see it's
a very difficult thing to do things in
space but maybe ultimately we will have
the capability to leave Earth and fly
elsewhere but my personal guest is that
we won't and in the fact is we the zero
breast is so vast and the places to go
are so far apart that we will never have
the capability not for doing it and if
that's case then we're sort of like one
of these Pacific Islands and we are
living on an oasis in space that's a
very special place and we're living here
in a very very special time and and I as
I said before I think you know our ad -
- towards us from a scientific attitude
is that we should be very pleased that
we live in such a terrific place so
thank you very much and I'll be here for
questions and
any questions from the audience yes name
is John Rock - I'm looking forward to
having you come and speak at our
conference in May okay having read your
book I noticed that you're encouraging a
dialogue on what you have to offer us
and so how would you want that dialog to
proceed what are you hoping for in terms
of a dialog from the people who are
reading your book dile well I I would
you know III would when we gone into
this book
we're eyes that only a few people had
really seriously thought about the
long-term future of the earth and I
would like to see a lot of people get
really serious about it and really dig
into what the details like you know as
far as I know no one has scientifically
ever studied how the earth ocean is lost
to space and for the biological
standpoint you know what what well
biology do when it starts getting
starved by carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere and what will it do when the
ocean currents change when the
continents go back together there's lots
of very fascinating questions and all
this is actually quite central to
astrobiology because it's a great
practical situation now that you know we
do have missions to discover earth-like
planets around other stars this a nasa
mission called Kepler which is an
improved mission and its goal is to
detect hundreds of earth-like planets
around other stars so you know within
decade or so we will know a lot more
than we do now about earth-like that's
all the planets that have been
discovered around those stars so far our
Jupiter and Saturn like like plants are
big gas Jessica gas giants just because
of the techniques that are being used
but ultimately we want to know you know
really are there Earth's out there and
how earth-like are they you know how
rare really are are we
yes how the carbon that makes up life on
Earth came from previous stars that had
he had finished their lifecycle and
exploded or whatever when when the earth
is toast and the carbon that was here is
again dispersed is there a sense in
which that again gets recycled somewhere
yeah there will be other planets formed
up yes yes it will yes the if the earth
gets ground up in the Sun probably many
of those atoms a large fact those atoms
will actually go out into space so there
is this recycling you know in rear earth
we had a comment something like you know
stars plant cell growth come and go but
atoms are forever which is actually not
true that there there is recycling but
it doesn't go on forever the actually
the whole universe runs down on the very
long term so but preferred next you know
couple the whole universe you know stars
evolve planets evolved the whole
universe also of also you know there was
very exciting and announcement just a
couple of weeks ago about new
information about the age of the
universe the prophecy universe we can
also study now about how the whole
universe of balls with time and they're
actually some quite awesome things that
happen the long-term future it's it's it
really staggers the mind if you like to
think about the universe in a rational
way and even all the scientists involved
in are also staggered to think about
these really long term things I mean it
just it's like like for instance a
universe with no particles you know with
just photons things like that but it on
very long timescales all the stars burn
out for instance but you know but wait
we should really only deal with our
little niche in time and not worry about
you know what what the future long-term
future brings I mean because we have no
way of knowing it
or you know did there any effect on us
directly yes back here hi when the the
carbon source in the atmosphere finally
gets depleted that would mean that the
simplest carbon sources would be in the
ocean so slowly things will work their
way kind of back to the ocean now so as
long as the ocean survives as a medium
complex life could still obviously exist
right yeah so it'll slowly break away
from that it but are there any other
molecules in the atmosphere that may be
something beyond photosynthesis could
use to also produce well as animals we
need oxygen you know and so just the
carbon dioxide but you know oxygen
itself would not have another pathway of
getting to the atmosphere no I don't
think so no okay you know so everything
everything goes so yeah it's interesting
you talked to the that we had there was
a big meeting of the American
Astronomical Society in Seattle about a
month ago and there was a astrobiology
session in this astronomical meeting
sort of a historical first and one of
our microbiologist University gave a
talk there and he quite proudly pointed
out that the earth is a microbial planet
and you know from his perspective all us
big creatures aren't very important he
says well if you scrape all the stuff
off the surface the microbial underworld
is just as happy and can you know it's
very tough that can live it you know
from freezing to boiling temperatures
and it doesn't have much environmental
requirements and continues on so it's
really it's a very interesting thing and
that this whole concept of microbial
plants versus you know star wars type
type plants is only really recently been
feeling fully realized so I think yes
we've been doing research on like
biodomes and whatnot right and I guess
what I've read in a lot of popular
science magazines is they're looking
forward to building a resort on the moon
that only wealthy people will really be
able to attend I when it first comes up
but that they're trying to incorporate
life on to the moon and then eventually
Mars if that's possible at all what's
your take on that yeah
colonization of other bodies the solar
system it is possible I mean we can do
it I mean that people have lived on the
moon there are 12 people that have lived
on the moon there are still trustfull
microorganisms left behind they're
living there right now whether we will
do that is an open question I mean we we
we inhabit Antarctica which is a very
hostile environment the cost is
tremendous is ten thousand dollars a day
for a person to live in Antarctica
because of all this you can't grow crops
very you know with technology we use
right now death us be hauled in so we
could have people living permanently on
the moon but they would have to have you
know material shuttled back and forth
from Earth and it's very expensive it's
much more difficult on Mars
many people feverishly believe that we
we will do that but you know I don't
know I mean I can imagine going either
way I mean you know we are a juncture in
time when ambitious space travel by
humans could disappear you know with
with a shuttle disaster some people
aren't asking that question do we really
want you know should we do this and can
we do it I I've asked a lot of people
and I think about 35 or 40 percent of
the people I ask think it's it's
inevitable that we will do this kind of
kind of thing but it's very difficult
doing things in the solar system we can
do it's it's traveling outside of the
solar system on any kind of reasonably
short timescale that's a that's a huge
question it even the most fanciful
propulsion system using
antimatter propulsion still to send a
rocket from here to the nearest stars
takes like the energy output of the
earth for a hundred years just to make
the fuel hit even if we can make the
fuel so their their arguments like that
that just make it very difficult it's
easy to send people to the nearest stars
if they don't eat and go to the bathroom
and then that kind of thing and if you
don't mind taking fifty thousand years
to get there you can do that right right
now but a practical sense of sending
living people there on their lifetime
even countable whether the back of ten
of their present lifetime is is very
difficult and extremely expensive and
from the aspect of the earth might be
rare
you know you enter the star you won't
know what's what's there before you go
you might get there and not like it and
there's no way back and and and also you
know just getting to another place and
stopping and doing a lot of it it's much
more difficult it looks like on TV I'll
guarantee you that yes recently I heard
in the radio that 96% of the universe is
either dark matter or dark energy
whatever that is yeah they also said
that the universe is expanding it'll
keep expanding it's not going to implode
on itself so that raises the question if
that's the case was their own was this
is this the only Big Bang there ever was
or for the previous Big Bang I I don't
know I don't know I I I feel Peter Ward
my co-author and I felt extremely
comfortable in dealing with times of
billions of years I'm I work on
meteorites and I hold the meteorite in
my hand it's four and a half billion
years old made fournette billions Peter
works on fossils that range from you
know hundreds of millions to billions of
years old so so billions of years we can
handle pretty well you get sore things
that are you know much longer than that
to me it's difficult to grasp
but it is true the universe is a very
peculiar place the fact that
most of the gravity is from dark matter
and dark energy not the manner that
we're made out of it doesn't interact
with us in any any way but it and the
long-term fate of the universe that
there's a interesting book called the
five ages of the universe by Fred Adams
and Laughlin that talks about these
various things will happen that very
long in future and I to me personally I
can really get into what happens on the
earth because I live here I'm an
inhabitant of the earth and it's my
backyard and the timescales are about
right you're talking about trillions of
years in the future I don't know that's
that's like a different different
universe to be but any further questions
yes I just wanted to to say that having
read your book and what's likely to
happen with our life forms although you
haven't really sketched out you
deliberately sort of left out the fate
of the human species yeah it's pretty
it's pretty obvious you know just
putting in the context to your book
human species has only been around a
fairly short time and we only have a
fairly short time to evolve before this
particular species is gone just as in
the individuals ago the species ago the
earth will go but as far as exploring
the universe is concerned as you say
life is going to get simpler and the
planets going to get simpler in your
book and ultimately we'll be back to
microbial life again but we have a
window of opportunity now to develop
machines as possible that we can develop
robot intelligences that won't be able
to carry on and essentially we're
evolving a non-biological form of life
perhaps yeah and if it gets to that
point that's what we'll explore the
universe that's what we'll carry on it
could even bring the seeds of human
species once again and so at an
appropriate place of that's found which
some people believe happened here it's
possible but in any case that's really
the only future for our species up since
this planet ultimately won't be
non-existent
yeah and it isn't and it is
it's it's I mean the the cycle of
processes is curving on this planet is
the natural process I mean maybe maybe
people can evolve and transform
themselves to you know silicon chips or
something
and escape the sort of the wet life
constraints that we have done but maybe
that maybe that's possible but just
following the normal biological
evolution it is the natural cycle where
well we like or not nature is is what it
is and like like people and other things
stars and planets have a cycle about the
the human population we of course didn't
talk much about that because no one
knows you know you're much safer talking
about things that are far in the future
then you are local things like you know
what the weather is gonna be like in
three weeks or something but Peter and I
are optimistic that that that humans are
different than other animals and we ABAB
will adapt and we do have the potential
for changing nature and there have been
success stories on earth most animal
species go extinct within a few million
years and depending on how we consider
where we started we're sort of at that
time a last picture here I show this is
a not a Lloyd that's something that
Peter Ward works on and it's also has a
great picture of him diving with one of
these in the South Pacific is there no
there's not a Lloyd you see in curio
stores all over the place this not
alloys have been a huge success story
they have lived on this planet as
animals for almost half a billion years
so there is the potential that among the
last animals to go would be humans and
that we you know with craftiness and
adaptability that go beyond normal
biological balance we might be able to
go very long impaired time and even you
think about living out on Pluto with
heaters and refrigerators maybe you can
you know people could live even the
solar system
for a period time beyond which were the
earth was completely uninhabited or even
in completely artificial environments so
I guess in the realm of science fiction
and no one can really say what's
practical or not I I tend to take sort
of a dimmer view than most people but
but but no one no one really knows but
it is a very fascinating subject so any
one more question yeah you've you've
mentioned that you've talked about
though some of the ways that humans have
an effect on the Earth's atmosphere and
obviously people have had an effect on
the on the history of evolution through
the kinds of extinctions that we are
causing and also what we're doing with
the atmosphere during the Industrial Age
do you think that human caused effects
will have any appreciable influence on
the history of life on the planet as you
describe it in the timescale that you're
talking about well on the longest time
scales they have no effect whatsoever
about the short term they have a huge
effect I mean I mean Peter feels very
strongly about as a paleontologist he
feels very strong about preservation of
species you know extinction is forever
you know unless that can be reclone
somehow and so he thinks there's a
disaster right now the rate of
extinctions that are there going on on
this on this planet so we really
shouldn't worry about what's gonna
happen hundreds of millions of years
from now you know we can think about it
in curious ways and it's I think it's
valuable to know what realistically what
are what the life cycle plan says but
the things that we should really worry
about it thinks we can we can influence
which the things we're doing right now
and how it affects us yes one last
question
quick if you don't mind if I go back to
antimatter engines I read a bit about it
a while ago in some articles that were
in some magazines and whatnot and I've
spoken with my father about a lot of the
like the subject material whatnot and it
is possible correct to go half the speed
of light using antimatter engines and
how far the process are they building
these engines no no no buts that
flippantly but rocket propulsion has
changed a heck of a lot since the
Chinese invented a couple thousand years
ago I mean we have liquid fuel engines
word you know and invented in in in the
last the last century most the
development of engines the United States
occurred in the in the 50s and 60s and
there have been you know some
refinements says then but not nearly as
much as people people would like one of
the dramatic changes has been the
development of ion drive there was a
recent spacecraft flew past a common
called deep space one belt by each other
pulsing lab and that uses ion propulsion
which is a radically different technique
ion propulsion Hathi has been used in
space for variety of things but here on
deep space one of us actually use as
propulsion but but not one is actively
you know working on really exotic
propulsion so beyond that the actually
the most exotic thing that people talk
about is if something that's actually
not very popular the outside wells
nuclear electric propulsion deep space
one use what's called solar electric
propulsion uses an ion drive engine but
the energy that drives it comes from the
Sun on on solar panels and that's great
if you're close to the Sun you get
across the Sun you way from the Sun you
don't have any power power isn't really
you know power we have abundant power on
earth and we have this incredible fossil
fuels everybody complains about fossil
fuels but we would not be here if those
plants and animals hadn't died back you
know hundreds of millions years ago to
make all that coal in the oil because
the civilization has depend
the source source of energy but in
general energy is very difficult if we
wanted to go to the moon or we wanted to
go to Mars there is no great source of
of energy I mean you can get little
energy from solar panels but but not the
great amounts of power that the people
normally use well thank you guys for
coming and Donald Brownlee is co-author
of the life and death of planet earth
it's published by times books an imprint
of Henry Holden company visit Henry Holt
comm for more information
you're watching 48 hours of nonfiction
book